[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Hi, and welcome.
We're here at the Security Zone
at Next with Lorena Crowley,
a phishing expert
at Google Cloud.
LORENA CROWLEY: Hi, Yufeng.
Happy to be here.
YUFENG GUO: So, phishing attacks
are an increasingly difficult
threat for security teams
to deal with these days.
LORENA CROWLEY: Right.
And one of the
most common attack
vectors that phishing
attackers use to trick
users is phishing websites.
YUFENG GUO: Wow.
Can you explain how and why
attackers create these phishing
websites?
LORENA CROWLEY:
Phishing attackers
create sites that are
designed to trick employees
into clicking on a link,
downloading a file,
or providing
sensitive information.
These phishing websites look
like legitimate websites,
so it's very difficult for
employees to spot them.
And attackers are creating
millions of these websites
and putting them all over the
web to try and trick users.
YUFENG GUO: Wow.
So that means employees
across all sorts of companies
are clicking on these
links to the sites
and accidentally finding
them while browsing.
And what happens then when an
employee opens up these sites?
LORENA CROWLEY: Well, let's
take a look at some websites
and see it from an
employee's point of view.
So let's say you're browsing
the web and open some sites
from your emails and you
come across these websites.
Let's see if you can spot
which ones are legitimate
and which sites are
actually phishing websites.
YUFENG GUO: OK.
I'll give it a shot.
Well, this one looks
like a financial website.
So-- and I think, well,
the URL looks good.
I'm going to say
this is a safe site.
LORENA CROWLEY: Correct.
Nice work.
That is a legitimate website.
Let's try another.
YUFENG GUO: All right.
Try it again.
And, well, this just
looks like the Gmail login
and, yeah, that
seems reasonable.
See that pretty often.
Oh--
LORENA CROWLEY: Oops.
No, that's actually
a phishing website.
It's hard to spot some of these.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
So what happens then when I
fall for one of these phishing
sites?
LORENA CROWLEY: Well,
in this example,
you may have given away some
of your credential details.
But the site could
have also tricked you
into providing other information
that's important, like company
data or other sensitive info.
Attackers are constantly
creating more of these phishing
sites and they're getting more
sophisticated and difficult
for users to spot.
In fact, a recent report
estimated that 1.4 million
of these phishing sites
are created every month.
YUFENG GUO: Wow.
So employees are just going
to be increasingly coming
across these
websites by accident
and via targeted attacks.
LORENA CROWLEY: Right.
But luckily, there
are some tools
for companies to
protect employees
from phishing website attacks.
One of those main
tools companies can use
is Safe Browsing
through Chrome browser.
Google is constantly
scanning the web
and identifying malicious
phishing websites.
These phishing websites are
then stored in a blacklist
on Google's servers.
This blacklist then gets
synced with Chrome browser.
So when an employee opens a
malicious phishing website,
the website is
automatically blocked
and the user sees this warning.
YUFENG GUO: Great.
So even if an employee opens
up one of these websites,
Chrome can detect it and
alert them before they open up
the website.
LORENA CROWLEY: Exactly.
Chrome browser stops
these employees
from accidentally
putting sensitive data
into the hands of attackers.
YUFENG GUO: That's really great.
And so how does this
work with Google Cloud's
other phishing protection tools?
LORENA CROWLEY: That's
a great question.
Protecting against
phishing website attacks
is only one part of a
phishing protection strategy.
Tools like Chrome browser
work seamlessly with Gmail
for email phishing
protection and security
keys for strong
two-factor authentication
to provide companies with
end-to-end phishing protection.
YUFENG GUO: Well, Lorena,
thanks so much for walking us
through how Google Cloud
can protect employees
from phishing attacks.
LORENA CROWLEY: My pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]